[Music]
so look I haven't read a ton of really
any of your tree Spencer's writings I
know who he is just a little clips that
I've seen things like that even if he
could convince me that a white ethno
state is the right thing I wouldn't I
would never agree that should be the
United States it's the reverse of what
the United States would be for him
shouldn't he maybe be trying to have
that white ethno state somewhere else if
that if that's what you try decide I
know you're going to invite him on the
shire and I think lawyer but you mean
like if you're trying to do here that's
against all of the the whole
Constitution and premise of the United
States of America you know I'm far more
fascinated because obviously I don't
have you waited nipple I don't think so
I mean obviously I don't I don't see I
mean I see like socialism super utopian
I see the white ethno state in America
specifically super utopian as well like
utopian idea you've got interesting
movements in like France and everything
right now though or the gauzy
identitarian is talking about France
belongs to the French people and I find
those arguments far more fascinating
than the ones in Canada and America are
doing for ethno states they're super
nutopia and it's not going to happen
right I think it's actually a really
interesting question to ask should
Denmark remain a majority Danish people
and if you talk to liberals may tell
them like should Japan remain majority
Japanese like absolutely right all right
I think it's I think that's a far more
interesting argument than kind of a Pepe
bring back the white to power in America
arguments and there's a lot more
intellectuals in that movement in Europe
kind of as well yeah how serious is that
whole thing I think one of the biggest
issues that were adding right now is
people can't really tell how serious the
situation is in Sweden you know there
was this whole thing with Trump last
week and then he sort of backtracked it
a little bit then he reversed the
backtrack and all that but what's going
on in Sweden and Germany and France and
now Holland guelder's probably is going
to be elected and really Marie lepen and
Fred like how serious is the immigration
situation well I think people have
reason to even if it's not so so serious
yet which I think it is a lot more
serious than obviously the mainstream
media is portraying I think people have
reason to be
worried I mean you saw I think you had
an Carlin on your show recently I was
listening to one of his podcasts
prophets of doom it was a really good
one to be listening to it right chances
it was about a monster in Germany where
they had the Lutheran's and the
Anabaptists living in this city and the
Anabaptists were kind of these radical
like communist Christians and they were
trying to grow power in the city of
Munster and as soon as they became the
majority and got more positions in
government these religious radicals what
did they do they started asking all the
Lutheran's there to lead to the point
where they were like we got to kill the
Lutheran's Rea as soon as they got a
majority so what happens when you get a
Muslim majority in France what happens
when you get a Muslim majority in London
you already see it happening in places
like Luton where you have Tommy Robinson
who gets beat up on the street for for
being white in illusion where you grew
up I was talking to a Pakistani guy in
might remember the other day
in fact I recorded this I probably
should know this broader conversation
because people don't believe me when I
turn on this his family moved to Luton
and he was telling me he's like I can't
tell anyone this by I don't want Wheaton
to be majority Pakistani they've changed
it I moved to Luton because I wanted to
live I wanted to live in Europe but I
didn't want to live in Pakistan we left
Pakistan for a reason and now we've
changed the area yeah and somebody moved
to Canada I think is learning with
Pakistan right and China has its own set
of problems yeah right what is through
those position on immigration unite
I mean after he met with Trump he was
basically saying we'll take everybody
because Trump was like no we're not
going to take anybody but that's not a
real conditioner position of diversity
is our strength that's like that's a
real face that you think I'm joking but
like you have I Chrystia Freeland who I
think she's one of our ministers
she was on Bill Maher and they were
talking about Islam and the threat of
radical Islam and she literally there's
an amazing video of it on YouTube if
people can find it he kept asking but do
you worry about radical Islam and she's
like suggesting that so I saw everything
you're saying it's like Farsi other
string figures to be the strength they
rescue the street and they just keep
repeating it that's a Liberal government
that's the sea
they just keep repeating diversity is
our strength and once again this goes
back to I think that kind of stuff is
leading to a rise in more extreme right
because they're not getting answers to
their worries about immigration from
Italy quick legitimate questions exactly
yeah I mean that's what I spent two
years when I talked to all the people
when I had Sam Harrison marginalized and
ayaan Hirsi Ali and Douglas Murray and
Milo and and Tommy Robinson by the way
look I like Tommy Robinson you know I
got a lot of [ __ ] for having him on just
for talking to the guy and he strikes me
now when I see what he's tweeting about
extremely moderate like someone that
cares about his country I I can't say
off the top of my head I have ever seen
him tweet something that I thought was
blatantly racist there may be some he's
in it on such a personal level where
where he's been punched in things where
I can't if I'm not defending an old
Twitter account but really like I see
someone that's actually basically trying
to do something good yeah and I think
you're going to see a lot more liberals
especially in Europe especially in
France you're already seeing it where
people probably shape we have a problem
here and the Liberals admitting we have
a problem here and it's going to become
more and more mainstream as soon as that
it this summer there are six million a
report was just released I in Germany I
believe that there are six million
people waiting in the country of
surrounding the Mediterranean to come
into Europe and as soon as that ice
melts you're going to see the waves and
waves of refugees come again and if
Turkey can't hold them if they're going
to be coming through Italy's they're
going to coming through costs and all
the islands in Greece you're going to if
they don't stop it you see some huge
problem that's why Eastern Europe is
building walls
that's why Eastern Europe closed their
borders like Poland Hungary Croatia
they're saying no because they are at
the forefront of the battle it's it's
Northern Europe that are kind of like
getting the few people that are making
it through right that don't have that
sense of urgency yet right that's really
interesting because even just I think
this morning I saw something about how
hungry is building this law right now
and their prime minister said something
about having you know a nationalist
state and then I saw immediately people
were tweeting odd this is like Hitler
and this is like Hitler and he wasn't
talking about killing anyone he wasn't
talking about
of kicking anyone out of his country he
was talking about defending his borders
but our conversation has just become
idiotic about it well it's all the
people that are sitting in their condos
that have security and they're in a
white neighborhood and they just kind of
get to sit there on their leather couch
and tweet out how dare you but as soon
as their community gets filled with
radical Islamic Moroccans or something
there or Somalis or especially a lot of
people coming from certain areas of
Africa but have very high violence rates
when they come into Europe if that
happened to their neighborhood
they'd either move and not talk about it
and pretend it didn't happen so they
could keep their job or they would be
pissed as all hell just like the people
that are living in these situations now
yeah so I think the second time that I
admire on I kept saying to him that he
doesn't make the distinction between
Islam the set of ideas that Islam is
versus the the nominal Muslim person who
may or may not take his faith seriously
who certainly is engaging in anything
terrorist related or anything like that
who wants to be part of the Western
world you do make that distinction right
in my book I referred to it as there's
three different title of your book cause
it's going to be barbarians on the big
agura's immigrants and Islam screwed my
generation know now I read you've said
Islam meeting the set of ideas not
Muslims meaning the people which I do
think you have an important point to
keep bringing up even though it for a
certain amount of people they're going
to say you're a hater no matter what but
yeah I mean sometimes I slip up and all
the things Muslims kind of like the left
you know I understand why people say it
because it just becomes simple for them
and they just assume people know what
they mean right but in my book I
separate into three different kinds the
scholar and I have a good friend of mine
who I would consider one of these and
he's very very into like very peaceful
very into the texts of Islam he had some
fascinating debates with me and in fact
he's actually very I throw like
identitarian movement in Europe and
Europe being for Europeans which i find
fascinating even though he's super
Muslim he's like no I understand what's
going on they're just very logical right
and then you've got the kind of the
Muslim that's kind of born into a Muslim
family and they don't really care
especially if they're in like America or
Canada or something it says that's my
that's like a Christian who doesn't
really go to church that's what I so
basically like every Jew and Christian
that we know in America pretty much yeah
yeah and they don't care that much but
the problem with these people is because
it's tied to their family they will
defend it no matter what so if they
they're going to write articles being
triggered about it in BuzzFeed like I
think a lot of these Muslims that work
for about students out there that kind
they don't really pay attention to their
face
I finally unfollowed and yeah I couldn't
take it anymore
it was offense the most ridiculous sects
of Islam and they'll be the ones
claiming Mohammed is a feminist and one
drives because it's their family it's
tied to them and they don't care they
can do no wrong and so that I find these
ones a problem as well simply because
these LEM has issues and it needs to be
criticized and if you're just supporting
it because of your family I have that's
an issue and then of course the radicals
the ones who believe in me very very
strong violent sections of the Quran and
hadith and Sharia law which is
horrifying obviously especially in the
countries where it's been implemented so
those those three of course the first
one should never be led into any Western
nation in like opinion and the second we
don't want to let you goddess to no I'm
very radical I want that position okay
no jihadist and yeah were with you yeah
and then I think you need some serious
screening for the second one as well the
ones that are born as these families and
just think why we should throw gays
offering that's cool yeah whatever I'm
not really gonna I'm not going to do
with my whole summer I do it myself but
I kind of support it and of course if
you had been Shapiro I believe on the
show he did a really good video the myth
of the tiny most radical Muslim minority
where he talks about the pew research
behind it showing that actually a lot of
people in this group are pretty okay it
was a lot of the radical policies being
promoted in Islam and I went to places
like mall and beak myself when I go to
the people there and they told me to
work at Sharia sounds good to me
what happens when these people it's
going to be Munster in the anabaptists
all over again what happens when these
people are the majority in these
countries
yeah they're gonna have an issue so easy
you just destined to fail then because
it is it really over I mean I
to me it looks like you know breakage
the string was pulled and now it's just
going to be a slow unraveling although
if what you said before about these six
million people happen quickly unraveling
could happen but we'll see it depends
what kind of deal they make with Turkey
depends if these deals work out and if
they manage to stop it because you're
seeing a lot of you're seeing the Merkel
walk back and be like maybe I messed up
with all the kind she prober cab and now
yeah like she's but that's obviously her
virtue signaling cause she wants to win
and not get too good office like all all
politicians all right you're seeing them
walk it back and realize oh [ __ ] we
messed up so the interesting is it
totally depends on the response and
deals that can be made to keep this
large wave from coming in yeah turkey by
the way is building a wall have you seen
this
Turkey's no I know they're building a
wall with Syria nobody seems to have a
problem with there well you know Jays
let in so many of the Isis fighters from
Europe into Syria and they let people
from Syria into Europe so turkeys had it
both ways or soccer you can have a
revolving door that turkey is a very
scary situation there the there that gap
between all hell breaking loose in the
Middle East and Europe so oh it's scary
watching a situation I mean there you go
there the gap yeah a lot of ways they
are then we really are screwed because
clearly they've gone down the more
authoritarian route with her on so well
so give them enough heroes I mean
everyone speaks money so baby were to
bite him off yeah essentially that's
kind of like huge palace have you seen
the palace that this guy with vivid air
no one's mad man yeah so who are some
politicians that you like right now what
I like right now who do you think's
doing it right right now that's making
some sense out of this stuff obviously I
like rain upon your welders Maxine
Bernier in Canada and the only reason I
support my same burning in Canada even
though I think he's a little softer on
he lose softer than like the dirt wild
boulders and stuff is we don't have as
much of a problem as Europe with
immigration we already have a pretty
comprehensive immigration we aren't
bordered on a third world country which
is the biggest thing Canada give America
a chance exactly yeah
no wait that's like Canadians are such
[ __ ] quite frankly because they don't
have real issues to deal with we aren't
bordered on one of the we are bordered
on America we've got America to defend
us so we're not worried about our
military we're not worried about our
borders we're so we watch the rest of
the world and we judge we're like you're
so mean you're so totally is and we
don't have to deal with any of it right
and that is a tremendous amount of space
Menace a lot of resources and everything
people take our oil and gas for granted
so much like we are the most biggest
spoiled brats on earth in Canada and now
we've elected an even bigger spoiled
brat than the rest of us so when you
talk about wielders and the pen every
article that I read about either one of
them says they're far-right right
does that have any meaning is there
anything that's right about them you
know there is a far-right about them
that you don't like do you think any of
their tactics are actually bigoted or
anything like that
well when the entire spectrum has moved
left of course they're going to be far
right I mean if you go back if you go
back 50 years ago and you ask a liberal
what their opinions are on like gay
marriage for example they'd be a Nazi
they say sorry and you know I could also
ask Obama seven years exactly not
success mating Trump is one of the first
politicians to go into office supporting
gay marriage so technically it could be
like most Pro gay president we've ever
had yeah look the guy got a standing
ovation at the RNC for talking about gay
marriage Peter Thiel gave an incredible
speech he protect he kept the LGBT
workplace protections and I got no
problem a trump on it but yeah if you go
back yeah go back to few years and all
your liberals are going to be far-right
today so do I have concerns about marine
lepen and gear Fowler's being Nazis
absolutely not because if you just kind
of turn that spectrum a little more
normal
oh no they're quite far away from the
Hitler end right yes I'm totally with
you on that but what what do you do then
if okay let's say they shut down the
borders or they get the most you know
just pitch perfect
immigration system and all of that stuff
and even if they stop letting in anybody
you still have a problem in the country
right now they know this for sure you
know Netherlands without question France
without question Germany they've all got
it or you there what do you do about
that well the first thing you have to do
obviously is the borders because that's
you can't solve the problem within so
once you've got that done the birthrates
obviously a huge issue I don't know if
you've seen it but people should look up
the PhysX on their own like the European
I like the French people versus the
Muslims within the country the birth
rates are exponentially different
they're just having so many kids and
like growing and taking over these
entire communities how you deal with
that well you stop this is this is one
of the biggest things that I've had a
problem with is my generation right now
native Canadian native your Europeans
Americans they are being taxed so much
in all the systems that exist today they
have become so generous with strangers
that they are unsustainable for
themselves so kids in my generation or
young Millennials they don't plan on
having children they don't plan it don't
even be able to own houses because they
can't afford it all of their money and
their parents money that should be going
to helping them is going to support
immigrants so start giving the money
back to the dated populations that do
want to have kids they're claiming it's
a birth rate issue and they're claiming
we need to bring more people into the
country so that we have enough people to
work the jobs whatnot and we have low
birth rates well then why are you
disincentivizing all these native people
from having kids and buying houses by
making it so expensive and getting all
of their money to immigrants I got yeah
yeah I've never heard that argument
that's a birth rate argument which we
know is extremely low for all these
westernized nations or you know for the
native populations in these Western
nations but it's actually a tax issue
well likely I would love to one day have
three kids I don't know if I'm going to
be able to afford that and we'll only be
able to afford one or two right and
anyone with a logical mind is going to
think about I want my kids to have good
education I want them to be able to eat
properly and healthy and whatnot how
many kids can I afford to have the
reality is most people can't afford to
have four or five kids if your wife and
all of your kit or all your wives are on
welfare
you know and you're going to be okay
yeah and you say wives but this is a
real thing exactly real thing and then
the birth rate thing also it's happening
in every Western country the most
popular babies name in Israel you know
what it is well maja Muhammad say in
London most popular name there in
Muhammad that's very very like people
would be having a collective panic
attack if the most popular name in like
an African country or a Korean country
was like Bob or something I'd be left
out I thought you were going to say
Hughes but just by yes Bob we're doing a
white name would be yeah Jim if Jim was
the most popular name did you can you
imagine how many hospice think pieces
would come out on that leg
imagine if you made neighborhoods
because I went into a neighborhood in
Germany that I was it called and trying
to remember
it'll come to me but I went into a
neighborhood in Germany where the
neighborhood Turkish flakes every one of
like huge Turkish flags all the cars
Turkish life
there was one German it was mark slope
there was like one German flag I saw on
a window and it literally looked like
the most depressing kind of pitiful
protest on conquered land it literally
looks like conquered lands what I was
looking at and do you think if Germany
went to war that against Turkey that
large slow would stand with Germany or
would it eat Germany from the inside out
would it fight with Turkey they would
fight with Turkey that is a fact imagine
if there was a place in Japan that you
went and it was all American flags
everywhere was all white community and
they were racist against the Japanese
there and they just were they didn't
speak the language they never bothered
to assimilate at all people would be
disgusted maybe discuss it and I'm
disgusted by or what's going on mark
flow I love freedom and I think that
people should have the right to put that
flag outside that doesn't mean I have to
support it that doesn't mean that I have
to be for it what do we do with the
media when it comes to this stuff
because this stuff is not getting
through to our mainstream media and
honest discussion of this stuff there's
a lot of it happening online and it
often happens on the extremes and I
think there's a couple shows I like to
think this is one of them we're having a
little more of a nuanced conversation
about this but how do we get this to the
mainstream so that before it's too late
here
the worry is always that people have to
suffer a lot before they actually like
realize I have a problem right now you
guys use how it is at the end of the day
I mean look what happened to America you
have you have bordering your cities that
are border to Mexico where you walk
through there and you're going to be
called a piece of [ __ ] gringo and yes
you know you in Europe you have Luton
you have moving places that are
literally being conquered and you look
at the oh my goodness the welfare rates
that go to immigrants especially from
Mexico and illegal immigrants in America
right now the Medicaid the food stamps
the housing all of it insanely high if
anyone looks at the research so of
course the American people have already
gone through a lot with what they're
dealing with and God knows like people
like Ann Coulter are saying it would be
if Trump's didn't win it would be all
over because they just keep voting in
Democrats so they have to get to a very
extreme point before they kind of woke
up to what was going on and there is a
shift going on we both know there's a
shift going on in the media at well in
popular culture rather yeah where people
are starting to push back and you're
seeing bigger and bigger figures come
out more and more I mean your video that
came out on why I left the last is
something that so many people refer to
as things are shifting look at David's
and Kings like this I don't love people
I know I mean I and what I tried to say
sort of in that video but what I've said
suddenly is I believe the exact same
things that I believed in 1988 when I
first got into politics instead of it's
great I've changed a little bit maybe on
some economic stuff I'm a little more
libertarian maybe than I used to be but
I believe the exactly it's not me
bitching people can say what you left a
left left left me right right yeah it's
I don't I mean I do understand how these
how these radicals took over but it's
amazing to see how quickly it happened
how quickly and effective the Tanners
hippies that were in the students to
shion's managed to plant that seed of
extremism in a whole generation of
people and get them into the media plant
them into the government and it's going
to be very interesting to see what
happens with this because my the tail
end of one eels obviously and the ones
that are just
going to be leaving University and
everything they are radicalized that's
done think things are changing now
especially with the kids in high school
that are more and more conservative
which is awesome I but what is going to
happen when all of these Millennials get
into government what's going to happen
when they start taking over the
companies what is going to happen it's
very interesting will they will they
change their mind when they start paying
taxes which in the theory that a lot of
rats or is the indoctrination to deep
right so that's like you know if you're
in your 20s and you're not a liberal you
have no heart and if you're not a
conservative in your thirties you've no
brainer yeah I might have changed I'm
hoping that natural cycle happens but I
don't think the indoctrination was as
bad one that quote yeah that's right
well safe spaces and trigger warnings
didn't exist exactly these kids have
been so insulated that I was supposed to
speak at UCLA or USC I think tomorrow
and they couldn't get enough security or
something so now I'm not speaking there
I mean yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]